ISIS' BEST KNOWN KILLER
PROVIDING OVER THE HEAD OF JAMES
FOLLY AND WESTERN HOSTAGES.
WITH EACH VIDEO HE'S TRASHED
TALK ENEMIES.
>> OBAMA, YOU HAVE STARTED YOUR
ARAB BOMBARDMENT THAT KEEPS
STRIKING OUR PEOPLE SO IT'S ONLY
RIGHT WE CONTINUE TO STRIKE THE
NEXT OF YOUR PEOPLE.
>> TONIGHT, A NEW AND BIZARRE
ACCOUNT OF THE CRUELTY HANDED
OUT BY JIHAD JOHN, THE MILITANT
IDENTIFIED BY WESTERN OFFICIALS
AS BRITISH NATIONAL MOHAMMED.
DANIEL RY SAYS ONE DAY QUOTE HE
PICKED ME UP AND I HAD TO DANCE
THE TANGO, JOHN AND I.
>> IT'S NOT REALLY THAT
SURPRISING HE WOULD HAVE THIS
KIND OF CLOCK WORK ORANGE SENSE
OF SINISTER HUMOR.
A LOT OF ISIS TROLLS ON TWITTER
WERE LAUGHING ABOUT THIS.
THEY THINK IT'S HILARIOUS.
>> IN AN INTERVIEW WITH DANISH
TV, RY SAID WHEN JIHAD JOHN WAS
TAN GOING, HE KEPT HIS EYES ON
THE GROUND LOOKING JIHAD JOHN IN
THE EYES HE SAID WOULD BRING A
BEATING.
HE SAYS HE WAS BEATEN ANYWAY
AFTER THE DANCE.
THEN RY SAYS THEY FINISHED BY
THREATENING TO CUT MY NOSE OFF
WITH PLIERS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
WHERE I WAS THINKING WHAT THE F.
>> THE GUYS THAT RUN THIS
ORGANIZATION, A LOT OF GUYS THAT
CONTROL HOSTAGES.
>> RYE SAYS HE WAS HELD
ALONGSIDE JAMES FOLEY AND WAS
RELEASED IN JUNE OF LAST YEAR
SEVERAL WEEKS BEFORE FOLEY'S
EXECUTION.
RYE'S FAMILY PAID A LARGE RANSOM
WHICH THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
DISCOURAGED THEM FROM DOING.
>> THE SURVIVORS OF AMERICAN
VICTIMS OF ISIS, JAMES FOLLY'S
FAMILY, THERE IS RESENTMENT
TOWARD THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
FOR SIMPLY NOT TAKING TO ISIS
DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY AS MANY
COUNTRIES HAVE DONE.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA CHANGED U.S.
POLICY AGREEING TO COMMUNICATE
WITH TERROR HOSTAGE TAKERS BUT
NO PAYMENTS.
FOR JIHAD JOHN, THEY WON'T SAY
WHERE THEY THINK HE IS.
>> HE'S A VALUED TARGET.
WE KNOW THE BRITISH GOVERNMENT
IS LOOKING TO STRIKE HIM IN A
BIG WAY BECAUSE HE'S DONE SO
MUCH DAMAGE TO